Benson returns to the big screen in the
new movie Wakefield he plays a father
who hides in the attic of his garage to
secretly observe his family Oh
the first call would be to my office you
know he hasn't come in you know oh
yesterday evening well then he didn't
say anything mm we left around usual
time oh yes of course I will
bye-bye
Oh what'd you do
[Music]
surprised card still there right welcome
back Ryan class good to see you rolling
stone call your performance a tour de
force of touching gravity and aching
humanism it gives everything and you
give it everything you have got what is
it you liked about Howard Whitfield why
in an odd way I related to him the
original short story was written by
Nathaniel Hawthorne back in 1835 and
then heal dr. o picked it up and wrote
it more current made at American but it
gave me a sense that mankind throughout
the decades and centuries rather felt
the same thing that at some point I want
to slow down my life I want to step back
I want to take an adult snow day and
just be you know Master and Commander of
my own time and that's what I related to
is I have because all of us everyone
feels like we're on this hamster wheel
constantly working is this it we're just
constantly doing this
can't we just slow down so his initial
interest was just to slow down and the
decisions he made sort of spun him out
of control Jennifer Garner plays your
wife and it's really a testament to your
acting because this that clip you showed
when you're looking out the window
you're not you don't even see her
you're acting to nothing when you're
looking out that window while you're
having this conversation to nothing you
look up there right and really what are
you seeing I'm seeing tape marks just
tape marks on a wall while you're no no
the cameras are there and there's
meeting the actual filming of it yes
yeah well we're actually framing it the
thing that got me about the movies you
and Jennifer Garner in a sex scene I I
watch it like this because you're both
so wholesome in my opinion so to see
that that we wanted you've got an image
you've got moves Bryan Cranston you got
that yeah we just intimacy what is that
intimacy course was that me Robin so I
corridor writer director felt that we
have very little time to actually put
this up and and we were supposed to be a
couple that knew each other very well
and for a long time so we didn't have
any time to rehearse so we took this
quick little intimacy course the two of
us I mean
come on come on you right now let's go
really okay come here where do we go
right here I'm gonna go right over here
Gail okay I made it over to you okay now
just just let it go right yes okay are
you gonna kiss me Oh see you're a little
uncomfortable hmm see and so if we're
just able to breathe in each other's
essence right we'll be real close hmm
then after a moment mm-hmm we can
actually touch each other's fingers and
you get a sense of trusting me and I you
mm-hmm and you're I I get a sense that
you're not as nervous now I can't do it
I can't do you really are touching me
yes I am and then it goes to this it
goes at this well actually goes from
from not touching to back to back we
feel our each we feel our body yeah yeah
just be present and then we touch our
fingers just just to get a sense it is
something sensual Charley about you it
is come on Charley
but how long was into me and intimacy
Korres what we did it we did it in a day
we took a crash course on works but and
I nearly does two or think it does it it
helped propel us to a point where we
felt and Jennifer and I were comfortable
each other and yeah one question did you
let yourself go there get giggles aside
I I could see where I could though more
for just and as I succeed and is this
intimacy course more than just for
actors like what is it generally use for
it you know I think you I think it can
be right I think we we in our in our
daily lives we get so out of touch with
each other that couples can can actually
take this course and go oh I've
forgotten how delicate that touch is how
so and to take our time to it to
reintroduce ourselves I think it applies
everything I mean how you do the tables
and touching everything in a sense of if
we forget our tactile senses let's not
get carried away
did you get on the table there we go
this is like the field the table you'll
get smoking from a woman who clearly has
been on a table okay I'm mad at jinora
manager the innuendo here is gonna be
replayed you know that no but it was a
very interesting role inside the two of
you react the way you did and to to come
together the way you did I thought was I
think that is very ecology of Howard
Wakefield means a little you did a
little bit for but he hides out in the
garage it's a man who wants to he wants
to not confront an issue with his wife
he had an argument with his wife and he
just wants to wait until everyone goes
to bed I'll I'll go upstairs then I'll
think about it and in the morning I'll
have an explanation of why I was out of
communication
he accidentally falls asleep in the
chair okay now I'll wait till the kids
go to school she goes to work and I'll
come in and I'll have all day to think
about what it and each move delays his
ability to make a re-entry into his life
and as a cautionary tale it becomes
elongated yeah how long was he actually
in the Attic because it was fascinating
how he watched his family how long was
he a buckaroo okay okay yes in there a
long time
a little bit seasons change a variation
of smell the roses take time to smell
the roses in a way yeah I mean it is it
does you know as a cautionary tale it
says take time yeah be be ever-present
and and check in with your life it makes
people wonder do they ever want to step
out of their lives and what they were
doing so yeah it raises a lot of
questions you're great in it Brian yeah
really read really loved you since
malcolm in the middle' how Bryan
Cranston yeah all right intimacy right
do the intimacy course thank you
Wakefield is now playing in New York
City it will have a wider release over
the Memorial Day weekend